me parece que ahora es un muy buen
momento para agregar algunas notaciones
y técnicas a nuestra caja de
herramientas de transformadas de la
plaza la primera cosa que les quiero
presentar aquí es una forma más rápida
de hacer algo y esto es si yo tuviera la
transformada de la plaza
la transformada de la plaza de la
segunda derivada desde hace algunos
vídeos probamos cómo hacer este
desarrollo vimos que la transformada de
la plaza de la primera derivada de james
es igual
s multiplicada por la transformada de la
plaza de g
- y evaluada en cero
y usamos esta propiedad en los últimos
vídeos para de hecho calcular la
transformada de laplace de la segunda
derivada ya que si decimos que esto es
la transformada de la clase esta
derivada pues podemos hacer una relación
de patrones aquí y decir también que
esto va a ser es igual a ese
multiplicado por la transformada de la
plaza de prima - de prima valuado en
cero
esto es la derivada de esto de la misma
forma que esto es la derivada de esta
otra parte
vamos a dividirlo aquí
y ahora podemos usar esto para
sustituirlo en esta parte
al menos que esto que estoy subrayando
en donde la persona de la clase de la
primera derivada de g
es igual a ese pueblo transformada de la
plaza de g
- y evaluar en ser
si sustituyo esto pues va a tener ese
multiplicado por todo esto menos prima
evaluada en 0 y cuando expandimos todo
esto que ya lo hemos hecho antes nos
queda ese cuadrado multiplicada por la
transformada de la plaza de y menos s x
evaluado en cero menos de prima evaluado
en cero
aquí hay algo interesante de observar
que si ustedes lo aprenden van a poder
hacer las cosas mucho más rápido y sobre
todo cuando se tiene poco tiempo y poco
espacio de papel para escribir en un
examen tomen nota de que cuando tomamos
la transformada de la plaza esta segunda
derivada con que terminamos terminamos
con s al cuadrado esta es la segunda
derivada y este es un 2 está al cuadrado
por la transformada de laplace de y
menos s porque evaluada en 0 menos ye
prima evaluado en 0 veamos que
comenzamos con s al cuadrado y en cada
término posterior se va a disminuir la
potencia de la s comenzamos aquí con una
escuadra da el siguiente término va a
tener una s con una potencia menor y el
último término no va a tener ese o va a
tener una s con una potencia en cero
después tenemos la función de valor en
cero y en el siguiente término está esta
misma función pero la primera derivada y
todos los demás términos son negativos
esa es una buena manera de recordar esto
sin tienen que ser todo el desarrollo
previo una vez que ya le encontraron el
modo esto voy a encontrar las
transformadas de laplace de cualquier
función que tenga
las arbitrarias por ejemplo digamos que
quiere encontrar la transformada de la
plaza
no sé de la cuarta derivada de y aquí
pongo el 4 en paréntesis en lugar de
poner los 44 comillas es lo mismo de más
para que quede más claro
y esto a que es igual si usamos esta
técnica de sustitución es muy probable
que nos equivoquemos y nos tardemos
mucho tiempo en tratar de encontrar el
error pero ahora ya hemos encontrado
cuál es el patrón y así que podemos
decir que la transformada de laplace de
esto en términos de la transformada de
la plaza de jeff que es lo que queremos
encontrar va a ser igual a ese elevado a
la cuarta
multiplicada por la transformada de la
plaza
todos los demás términos van a tener un
menos enfrente de ellos
- bajamos al grado de la potencia s a la
y aquí ustedes podrían tomar una forma
de derivadas de manera que tenemos
evaluada en 0 aunque la transformada de
laplace no es la anti derivada de pero
de todas maneras creo que ustedes tienen
la idea y vamos bajando el grado de la
potencia de ese de nuevo y nos queda
menos s al cuadrado y bueno por supuesto
estas son funciones ahora vamos a
evaluar la derivada de esta función en
cero
nos queda prima en 0
- bajamos la potencia una vez más s
multiplicada por la segunda derivada de
y evaluar en cero
y agregamos un término más donde
disminuimos por última vez la potencia
de s donde nos queda ese al hacer o
igual a 1
a menos
la tercera derivada de vamos a mover
esto un poquito para acá evaluada en
cero y creo que ustedes pueden notar el
patrón aquí esta es una forma mucho más
rápida de encontrar la transformada de
la plaza de una función que tiene una
derivada arbitraria en lugar de estar
haciendo todo este desarrollo una y otra
vez otra de las cosas que les quiero
mostrar aquí es acerca de las notaciones
es algo que ustedes pueden encontrarse
así que es bueno que conozcan de qué se
trata y también nos ayuda a ahorrar
espacio y tiempo en lugar de estar
escribiendo está el manuscrita la
transformada de la plaza
de una función dt
puedo escribir la o la gente tiende a
escribirla como
va a ser una función de ese y se usa una
mayúscula en términos de s para indicar
que esta es una función de s y esto
tiene sentido porque normalmente cuando
estamos haciendo una anti derivada si
tomamos el teorema fundamental del
cálculo donde tenemos la integral de la
función f de x
de 0 a x
que es igual a una mayúscula de x más o
menos está imitando esta anotación ya
que esta función de ese es más o menos
como la integral de 7 la transformada de
la plaza es hasta cierto punto un tipo
especial de integral ya que tenemos una
función exponencial ahí bueno voy a
quitar esta parte de aquí de cualquier
manera lo que quería yo es que se
familiarizaron con esta anotación cuando
vean una yema yus q la de ese se refiere
la transformada de las plazas de 7 y
también se podrían encontrar la
transformada de la plaza de ft
que es igual a f mayúscula de s
la pista para que ustedes no teme esto
es el hecho de que se está usando esta s
como variable independiente ya que en
general ese representa la frecuencia y
es por eso que la gente usa la s en
general para indicar el dominio de la
frecuencia para que no haya confusiones
bueno de cualquier manera estoy pensando
que tanto tiempo tengo para enseñarles
más conceptos fascinantes al respecto
bueno mi siguiente pregunta para ustedes
y en esta ocasión les voy a enseñar un
par más de propiedades que les van a ser
útiles cual es la transformada de la
plaza
al aporte multiplicado por el cdt
fascinante pues tenemos que regresar a
nuestra definición de lo que es
transformada de la plaza que es igual a
la integral de 0 a infinito
al menos 7 x lo que tenemos aquí entre
las llaves así que va a estar x al
aporte ft dt
y ahora podemos sumar estos exponentes
es decir que tenemos la misma base y
esto va a ser igual a la integral de 0 a
infinito
y bueno quiero a reacomodar un poco los
exponentes para que se note más claro -
s menos a por ti ustedes pueden de
expander esto y se notará que es
exactamente lo mismo que lo que tengo
aquí arriba en los exponentes por efe de
t de t
y ahora permítanme mostrarles algo si yo
simplemente fuera realizará transformada
de la plaza de ft la transformada de la
plaza de ft solita
eso sería igual a una función de s efe
mayúscula de s
cualquier cosa que tengamos en esencia
aquí va a llevar a una función en el
dominio de s así que esto es interesante
esta es una función de ese y aquí todo
lo que hicimos bueno de hecho permítanme
reescribir esto va a ser igual a la
integral de ser infinito de al menos s
porte por ft dt está transformada de la
plaza de la función ft solita es va a
quedar en una función de s
ahora la transformada de la plaza de a
la aporte x ft va a ser igual a esto
vamos a ver qué hay de similar entre
esto y esto que tenemos parecido bueno
aquí donde tengo una s tengo una s menos
a
así que si esto es una función de ese
esto que va a ser pues tenemos la misma
función cualquiera que sea de la
transformada de la plaza de ft tendrá la
misma función pero en lugar de s va a
tener ese menos a va a ser efe
mayúscula de ese menos al y de nuevo
como encuentro esto bueno si la
transformada de la plaza
efe que es una función de ese y es igual
a esto bueno si yo reemplazo esto con
una s menos a voy a obtener esto que es
una función de s menos a la cual es la
transformada de la plaza a la atp por ft
quizás esto les haya confundido un poco
permítanme mostrarles un ejemplo vamos a
encontrar la transformada de la plaza
el coseno
de 2 t
y nosotros mostramos que esto es igual
voy a escribir la notación a una función
de s una función en el dominio de s que
es igual a s / s cuadrada + 4
así que la transformada de la plaza
digamos
a las tres porte por coseno de dos porte
para ser igual a la misma función
fs sólo que en lugar de s vamos a tener
ese menos 3
que es igual a esta otra función es m3
entre s menos 3 al cuadrado
al cuadrado más 4
+ 4 noten que cuando estamos
multiplicando algo ya sea a la 3 t oea
la ate y queremos encontrar las
transformadas de laplace de esto va a
ser lo mismo que la transformada de
laplace de esta parte pero en todos los
lugares donde encuentra en una s la van
a reemplazar por la s menos este valor
espero que toda esta explicación les
haya quedado clara y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo